what is your take on like kind of LA
right now man because obviously we got
out of a pandemic a lot of people were
running up the EDD you know people have
uh
the robberies we always see it online
people getting robbed out here all the
time people losing their lives out here
artists getting killed out here like do
you I mean it's not like it wasn't
always lit out here you know what I'm
saying but I feel like now it seems like
it's just more publicized how do you
feel about just kind of the state of the
city right now I think it's just more
publicized because there's a lot more
ways that you could find everything out
you know it'd been dangerous you know
it's been dangerous I look at I've been
looking at it like it was dangerous yeah
but you know now like you said you got
camera phones you got the internet you
got everything so you know it's just you
know but but but but but I think you
know what's going on like been going on
it's just now you know yeah you know
that is true